2017 war erstmal ein paar jahre ruhe und
jetzt schlag auf schlag die nachrichten
über angriffe auf polizisten
das ist nicht ein einfacher kleiner
skandal genau darüber möchte ich jetzt
sprechen mit john cusack bei mir im
studio schon was genau soll denn jetzt
montagabend schon wieder passiert sein
ja ernst august ist tatsächlich nochmal
zur polizei nach scharnstein gefahren
das ist quasi die nächste
polizeidirektion um eine erneute anzeige
zu stellen wegen polizeibrutalität das
ist unser infostand zusammen hängt
natürlich mit dem einsatz und den
vorwürfen die er beim letzten einsatz
ging die polizei gemacht hat nur hat er
dort niemand angetroffen also hat er da
an geklingelt und wurde automatisch mit
dem notruf verbunden und der notruf hat
darauf hingewiesen sie können heute die
anzeige nicht aufgeben entsprechend ist
dann der prinz wieder zurückgefahren
muss sich vorstellen scharnstein
er muss nach grünau wo er wohnt und das
dorf das sich auf der strecke befindet
heißt mühldorf und mühldorf ist er dann
zufällig in eine polizeikontrolle
geraten nämlich mit dem polizisten die
eigentlich sonst in der polizeidirektion
werden und dort soll er angehalten haben
wir bei meinem taxi unterwegs hat das
fenster runter gemacht hat mit einem
baseball-schläger um gefuchtelt und die
beamten bedroht wurden uns aber auch
sagen im baseball schläger hatte er also
auch schon mitgenommen als eigentlich
der polizeiwache wollte was ja auch
schon nicht ganz normal ist ein
baseballschläger mitternacht mit ich
höre es ist noch nicht ganz genau
bestätigt wir haben heute auch noch mal
mit der polizei geredet
fakt ist aber dass er aus dem taxi
heraus mit diesem baseballschläger um
gefuchtelt hat die beamtinnen das waren
zwei polizistinnen bei dieser kontrolle
beschimpft hat und danach weggefahren
ist
ja und wir haben ja gerade schon kurz
oder gesprochen letzte woche gab es erst
einen vorfall mit ihm dort hat er zwei
beamte mit einem messerschleifer
angegriffen hat man in seinem umfeld
irgendeine erklärung dafür was jetzt
gerade mit ihm los ist gibt es
irgendeine begründung dafür dass er
jetzt tatsächlich so gefährlich auf
polizisten los geht
also bekanntes 1 ernst august war weil
dem letzten vorfall und obwohl auch bei
diesem vorfall alkoholisiert das
verändert menschen und kann reaktion
hervorrufen die man selber nicht
kontrollieren kann und im umfeld ist
eigentlich die überraschung groß weil
zwei jahre lang war es ruhig um ihn nach
einer ernsthaften erkrankung war lebte
er zurückgezogen in grünau auf dem
jagdschloss inmitten eines jagdreviers
nun dass es nun so zur eskalation kommt
liegt aber auch mit dem typen zusammen
es wird als dünnhäutig beschrieben ja
nachtragend sehr cholerisch und dieser
einsatz hat ihn offenbar sehr sehr
berührt fühlt sich ungerecht behandelt
und entsprechend ist ja noch mal auf um
eine erneute anzeige wegen
polizeibrutalität zu stellen und
vielleicht noch das neuer stand wie er
mit der staatsanwaltschaft gesprochen
es wird nun wegen ernsthafter drohungen
gegen ermittelt kombiniert mit den
anderen delikten steht immer noch eine
freiheitsstrafe von bis zu drei jahren
im raum wenn er verurteilt werden sollte
also ernste konsequenzen danke kommt für
diese neuen details dankeschön